alright so apple just released two brand
new ipads at their september event we've
got the new ipad 9 for 329
and the fully redesigned ipad mini 6 for
499.
and on the surface it seems like the
ipad 9 is just receiving an extremely
small spec update but in reality the
value of apple's basic ipad just went
through the roof which i'm going to
explain in this video but then again for
a hundred and seventy dollars more you
can get the new ipad mini 6 with the
brand new redesign that looks much more
modern and future proof so what i'm
gonna do in this video is go through all
of the new changes on each ipad and
explain why they're such a big deal and
then i'm gonna compare the feature
differences and give you guys some
practical advice on which ipad to buy so
without further ado let me first get
into the main changes with the ipad 9.
this year it's getting the a13 bionic
chip which is from the iphone 11 giving
it an 18 boost in terms of single core
performance and over 20 boost in
multi-core and a much larger 37 percent
boost in metal graphics performance on
top of that the a13 features a better
image signal processor which should
improve camera quality however it's
still sticking to the same three gigs of
ram as it had last year as far as the
display it now supports true tone which
basically adjusts the color temperature
of the display to match your environment
just like all of the other ipads have
done for a while but the most shocking
new feature is the upgraded selfie
camera which now features a 12 megapixel
ultra wide directly from the new m1 ipad
pro which also supports the new center
stage feature for facetime calls this is
a huge deal because the previous ipad 8
had a terrible 1.2 megapixel camera
which sucks for everything from photos
to facetime calls so a 10x improvement
is awesome and finally the last big
feature is that apple doubled the base
storage to 64 gigs and they're now
offering a new 256 gigabyte storage
option now while it seems like all of
this is a small upgrade this is actually
pretty huge because apple didn't bump up
the price tag at all it still starts at
329 dollars and you get all of these new
features and if you don't believe me
when i say this is huge let me remind
you that last year's ipad 8 only had one
upgrade from the previous ipad 7. it got
an upgraded a12 chip that's all so all
of those upgrades to the ipad 9 are
honestly much more than i expected since
apple fixed multiple issues that i had
with the old ipad even though they
didn't quite give it the laminated
display that i really wanted it to get
now with that said let's move on to the
changes with the ipad mini 6 but first i
want to point something very important
out to you guys until now the design of
the mini literally has never changed
since the very first model in 2012
almost a full decade ago so when i tell
you that the new mini 6's redesign is a
huge deal it is because not only has
apple redesigned it but they fixed
basically every complaint we've had with
the old model in fact they made the new
ipad mini 6 so good that it now
cannibalizes the ipad air 4 in multiple
ways so please do not buy the ipad air
until it gets updated again but getting
back to what's changed with the mini 6
it obviously gets the new flat sided
redesign from the air and the pro which
includes the removal of the home button
and a new rounded corner display this
change alone is huge because it's going
to make people feel safe about buying
the mini 6 as a long term purchase since
this design won't change for many years
on top of that another game changing new
feature is the switch to the usbc port
which makes it much more useful and
modern and because apple ditched the
lightning port they also had to make the
mini support the new apple pencil 2 with
the wireless charging magnetic cutout on
the side which is a hundred times better
than the old charging solution but one
of the most important new features for
me is the fact that apple finally gave
it speakers on both the top and the
bottom for true stereo sound which
completely changes your experience when
gaming or watching videos just like the
air and the pro it now features built-in
magnets so it supports apple's super
thin magnetic smartfolio which also
covers the front and allows you to
quickly stand it up on top of that the
new mini also gets the same new 12
megapixel ultrawide selfie camera that
comes on the m1 ipad pro and the ipad 9
which replaces the old 7 megapixel
selfie cam which couldn't even record
video at 60fps and as far as the rear
camera it's been upgraded to a 12
megapixel sensor with a faster f 1.8
aperture which leads to much better
camera quality and this time it actually
comes with a flash compared to no flash
on the old model and for video recording
it can finally shoot 4k at up to 60 fps
compared to 1080p at only 30 fps on the
old model and as far as the wireless
specs it features upgraded wi-fi 6
support and you can now finally get a 5g
model but unfortunately it doesn't
support millimeter wave for those who
have it in their area and finally the
last major upgrade is the brand new a15
bionic chip and thankfully it's actually
the 5 core gpu version from the iphone
13 pro models benchmarks for the ipad
mini 6 have already leaked and it looks
like it scored around 1600 points in
terms of single core and around 4 600
points for multi-core which seems to be
a down-clocked version of the a15 that's
going into the iphone 13 models but if
we compare the leaked scores to the a12
chip from the last ipad mini the new one
is now 43 faster in terms of single core
performance and a pretty nice 72
improvement in terms of multi-core but
the biggest upgrade we see is in the
metal graphics performance which matters
the most for things like gaming and
productivity work the leaked benchmarks
for the mini 6 show a metal graphics
score of around 13
700 a seriously massive two and a half
times more graphics performance than the
old mini 5. so when i say that this new
update to the mini 6 is the biggest that
we've ever seen i mean it now with all
that said before i get into my practical
advice for which one to buy let me
quickly list off the main differences
between both the new ipad 9 and the new
ipad mini 6. the mini is quite a bit
smaller which you can see in this
comparison image on apple's website
actually making it perfect for kids
especially since it comes in more fun
colors like pink purple and starlight
the mini obviously also gets a much
better design especially on the display
so it's going to feel modern for years
the mini has the better a15 chip
compared to a13 it has a better 12
megapixel rear camera with flash
compared to 8 without flash it gets the
much better usb c port and it gets the
second gen apple pencil which is more
convenient to store and charge on top of
that the display on the midi is actually
much better with a higher 326 ppi
resolution better color support with dci
p3 wide color gamut and the display has
an anti-reflective coating while also
being fully laminated so it doesn't have
a gap between the display and the glass
making it feel more solid and giving it
deeper blacks and of course the mini 6
features true stereo speakers on the top
and the bottom while the ipad 9 only has
stereo speakers on one side which don't
sound nearly as good and in terms of the
wireless specs the mini has wi-fi six
instead of regular wi-fi five and has
bluetooth 5.0 instead of bluetooth 4.2
but with all that said the ipad 9
actually has a couple of features that
the mini does not the ipad 9 is now the
only ipad that still comes with a
headphone jack while the mini 6 has
scrapped it this year the ipad 9 also
comes with apple's smart connector which
allows it to support amazing keyboards
like logitech's combo touch which
features a full keyboard and a trackpad
that actually works very well turning it
into a laptop replacement but the mini 6
unfortunately doesn't because it's too
small to have a keyboard attached to it
so with all of that out of the way
let me finish off with my practical
advice on which one you should buy if
you're the type of person who's been
looking at android tablets for yourself
or your kids but you're now considering
an ipad the ipad 9 is the one to buy
because it's the cheapest one at only
329 dollars and it now gets double the
storage and all of the new features for
a reliable experience for many years to
come or if you just want an ipad for
things like playing games and watching
videos while not spending that much cash
and you don't really care about the
design the ipad 9 is for you because it
comes with the a13 chip which is more
than fast enough for most games and apps
or if you just want to have a portable
laptop replacement in combination with
logitech's combo touch keyboard case
this is the cheapest way to do it now
moving on to the ipad mini 6 this is the
one to buy if you really care about
future proofing for the next few years
and you don't mind spending an extra 170
bucks to get the updated design and the
much better display this one is
definitely going to be more convenient
to hold in your hands while on the couch
or anywhere else because of the smaller
size making it an absolute dream for
gaming because of the stereo speakers
and the blazing fast a15 chip that's
gonna handle any app or game without
issue for many many years and when i say
future proof i mean it because it comes
with modern specs and features like 2nd
gen apple pencil support usbc and
updated wireless specs while the ipad 9
is basically using all of the old
technology and it obviously looks
ancient so in my opinion unless you
really need that smart connector for
keyboard support i would honestly spend
the extra 170
on the new ipad mini 6 because i think
there's a pretty good chance that apple
will totally redesign the ipad 9 next
year for the 10th anniversary model and
you're gonna be stuck with the old
design that nobody wants anymore but
then again if future proving isn't that
big of a deal for you and you just want
a new ipad without spending half a grand
on it the new ipad 9 is definitely a
killer value for everything that you get
so hopefully this video helped you make
a decision and if it did go ahead and
click the circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one and check out
our links below for these ipads and the
best keyboards down in the description
below but if you're still confused on
which ipad to buy comment your thoughts
below and we'll help you make a decision
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]